for me altruism is just about making
other people better off and more
precisely i just want to measure that as
just how many people are you affecting
and how significantly are you improving
their lives
and if in the course of that you improve
your own life as well as i think is
actually quite often the case that's a
bonus
hey everybody welcome to another
rollback where we bring the best of our
pre-video catalog to youtube for the
very first time
today's episode is all about effective
altruism or in other words what it means
to do good better and our guide for this
exploration of philanthropy is the very
wise william mccaskill
william is a scholar he's an author and
an associate professor in philosophy as
well as a research fellow at the
university of oxford even more
impressively at the time of our original
conversation back in 2015
william was only 28 years old and
already had been a research fellow in
philosophy from emmanuel college at
cambridge as well as a fulbright scholar
at princeton and had co-founded two
non-profits in his twenties
this is a pretty intense and at times
heady conversation that covers a lot of
ground including
the definition of effective altruism the
link between altruism and happiness
removing emotion from philanthropy
how to properly evaluate a charity
reasons to choose a career path and why
the sweatshop issue is more complex than
you think
william is an exceedingly bright and
incredibly impressive young man and it
was an honor and a pleasure to probe his
philosophical mind so i sincerely hope
you enjoy this exchange from episode 178
with me and william mccaskill
so many things to
uh talk about but i think probably the
best way to just is to just jump in and
get our feet wet uh why don't you kind
of explain
what effective altruism is and then we
can kind of go from there yeah terrific
uh so effective altitude is about using
your time and money as effectively as
possible to make the world a better
place so if you want to give to chavity
how can you make not just a difference
but how can it make you make the most
difference you can
if you want to do good with your career
what's the very best career you can do
in terms of having a social impact and
then we try to take
a scientific evidence-based data-driven
approach to answering that question
and that's turned into a bit of a
philosophy and a bit of a social
movement and there's now an effective
autism community all around the world i
know how does it feel to
to to be at the epicenter of like
catalyzing this entire social movement
uh well i was like
28 years old well i'm british so mainly
i just feel awkward about it um
how embarrassing exactly but i mean
exciting at the same time it's just i
really didn't expect these ideas to take
off in the way they have done and it's
been
so
exhilarating seeing people
you know really make very significant
changes to their life pledging to give
most of the money they earn over the
course of their life
making major career switch founding
non-profits founding companies uh all
with the aim of just really trying to
make the biggest difference right right
right and we're gonna get into all of
that but while we kind of like plan our
flag in this uh
world of altruism i mean i think that
it might make sense to even define
altruism in itself because i feel like
it gets confused like when i spoke to
ryan about uh stoicism you know it gets
confused with asceticism right and i
feel like
you know altruism can kind of fall a
little bit into that category as well in
terms of how people perceive it so like
what is altruism in and of itself yeah
thanks a lot for asking that so because
when biologists use the term optimism
they mean self-sacrifice and i think a
lot of people think that they mean
you're being altruistic that means
you're just making yourself worse off
for some other end
and that's not really how i want to use
it at all for me altruism is just about
making other people better off and more
precisely i just want to measure that as
just how many people are you affecting
and how significantly are you improving
their lives
and if in the course of that you improve
your own life as well as i think is
actually quite often the case that's a
bonus that's the reason in favor of
doing that thing right not reason
against is it your feeling that we are
naturally altruistic that that through
some
bizarre you know sort of natural
selection process that we are you know
we have arrived on the planet kind of
inherently altruistic or we have that
innate sort of characteristic as a
precept of natural law yeah i think
we're
i think it's we're to some extent
altruistic so maybe we're like ninety
percent out for ourselves and ten
percent altruistic yeah i'm not so sure
we live in the most altruistic culture
yeah i think it
it varies depending on which particular
subculture you're part of maybe wall
street not so altruistic the bailout a
little bit more at least um in how they
talk about things
uh but i think in terms of
human nature yeah i think there's a
strong altruistic component right i
think you know we see suffering
um in other people even in people we
don't know and we feel compelled to help
anytime a natural disaster spikes that's
in clear abundance and it's hard to make
sense of that on purely evolution right
self-interested grounds and so how did
you get uh initially interested in this
subject matter
yeah so i'd
been interested in doing good you know
i've been socially conscious kind of
growing up i plan a scout group for kids
with disabilities for many years i
worked as a
care assistant um an old folks home
uh-huh and that was absolutely i mean
what were your parents like
i mean my parents were
fairly regular kind of upstanding
members of the community they never
really pushed me
in any direction particularly they just
wanted to see me
uh flourish on my own and so a lot of
this stuff was kind of off my own back
self-generated thing yeah and then i
became vegetarian age 18 and i didn't
know that that was that didn't come up
in my uh research or now we have lots of
other stuff to talk about oh yeah for
sure so first of october 2005.
wow that was the day i left home and i
became vegetarian interesting and that
definitely wasn't encouraged by my
parents they were quite shocked
and so yeah i'd always been interested
in making difference and certainly
through studying philosophy a lot of
ethical ideas coming up and a lot of
arguments i found quite powerful
in particular peter singer's argument
that we have this obligation to give
most of our income to fight poverty
because
you wouldn't walk past a child downing
in a shallow pond um just because it
would cost a few thousand dollars for
you to run in and save the child and
muddy your suit and if that's true
what's the difference between that child
learning in front of you and a child
dying of an easily preventable disease
in a poor country on the other side of
the world and i found the argument
compelling that there isn't really a
morally irrelevant difference was that
an argument that you that you came upon
prior to him sort of entering your your
orbit and being kind of a mentor to you
oh yeah i came upon that argument age 18
or 19 and found it very compelling
immediately but didn't act on it right
not for years right right uh and it was
actually only after i graduated
cambridge which is where i did my
undergraduate degree
and over the summer i was working as a
fundraiser for care international
so one of those annoying people who
stands on the street and the cost passes
by
asking them to donate ten dollars a
month
uh in the uk we call them charity
muggers or
chuggers
and so i was a chugger
and it meant that all day every day i
was telling people about global poverty
and how much good you could do just by
spending your money in a different way
and every day i was getting these blank
apathetic stairs back at me people who
just
were take making any excuse possible to
dodge the arguments
and i thought these people just aren't
living up to their own values and i felt
very angry about that and then i thought
well i'm not living up to my own values
either i'm you know my plans at the time
was to go to grad school at oxford
continuing to do philosophy but doing
very esoteric subjects
philosophy of language philosophy logic
things that i honestly thought were very
intellectually interesting but weren't
going to write
not applied philosophy yeah exactly
and so that meant that when i arrived at
oxford i thought okay i'm gonna have to
start making changes to my life and i
started giving some of my graduate
stipend
um
like a couple of percent a few percent
which seemed like a very big deal at the
time in my head
uh and i started looking around talking
to academics asking okay well you know
including practical ethicists people who
are really engaging with real world
ethical issues and asking well what
impact did you have
and the chair of practical ethics at
oxford
who must be you know within that field
one of the most influential people i
asked him and he said that once someone
said that they joined the donor organ
legisly
um you got one email one email yeah one
person in this like 20-year career who'd
signed up to talk breaks my heart yeah
and he said that was the sum total of it
so i was pretty disenchant disenchanted
and so they were wondering what i should
do with my life
but then
uh by coincidence i met um another
academic called toby ord that was in
early 2009
and
we met because of
uh shared research interest but i saw on
his website that he hear this comment
that he says he was very concerned by
global poverty and give to the quiet
amount
and i saw that and i thought hogwash
he's just another one of these academics
he's not actually doing anything
but then he told me he was at the time
living on nine thousand pounds saving
two thousand pounds and giving two
thousand pounds and he was planning to
give everything he earned above twenty
thousand pounds
um
and he described it as a high bar um
uh he was planning to give more than
that in fact but if he was gonna pledge
something publicly he wanted to have a
safe amount but what was most striking
about it all
was how enthusiastic he was about this
he was not conveying this as this like
self-flagellated like a murderer or
something yeah exactly he was like this
is an amazing opportunity this is like
so exciting how much good we can do
and that really
inspired me as well
uh and so
together we then co-founded this
organization giving what we can which is
about encouraging people to give at
least 10 percent of their income to
whatever causes do the most good
and
i ended up taking a similar pledge to
him everything above
uh two that twenty thousand pounds per
year right inflation and
the cost of living adjusted
yeah let's explore that a little bit so
that's about 35 000 u.s right in that
range um
so did you do that shortly after that
conversation or how long have you been
on this program yeah i think a couple of
months afterwards
i actually
you know it was obviously a time of
turmoil for me and before making the
decision i
went online and just started looking at
um
photos of children
um suffering from horrific diseases and
because you know i wasn't
cognitively i thought i should do it but
i didn't quite have the emotional right
push um so i deliberately looked at
photos like that and i remember seeing
one child who had a
lymphatic filabiasis of the face so it's
quite a rare condition to get that it
meant the entire face was hugely swollen
and like sagging down almost like snoopy
the dog or something
and i just thought look if
my action here can stop like one person
just one child from not having to go
through a condition like that it's
easily worth it
and in fact if you look at the numbers i
can do that thousands of times over
and so that's when i made the decision
right and and did you what did your
friends think
why when you announced this to your peer
group um well at the time i was
facilitizing quite a bit yeah no so a
lot of people were like would say is
that legally binding
yeah come back in a few years and we'll
see whether you're still stuck with that
well it's a valid question i mean it's
one thing to make that pledge when
you're an impoverished student but you
know now you're sort of
you know as you escalate the you know
the world and your income increases i
mean do you
do you have like caveats for uh you know
adjusting for
not just inflation but you know as your
life continues to expand i mean if you
have children if you you know what i
mean like things enter into your life
where you know 35 000 a year if you're
making you know a decent quantity which
i imagine you will with all the work
that you're doing
um you know you're gonna confront like
some realities with that yeah so there
are some caveats so uh
one is for children so
if i'm a
parent with another if i have a child
and uh if i have a i'm a parent with
another
with a partner then
i would increase it by 5 000 pounds per
child
or 10 000 pounds if i'm uh
if i'm a single parent
and
i also have put in the kind of emergency
clause which is just
if it's the case that something
unforeseen happens or something i think
is yeah and it's going to significantly
impede how much good i think i'll do
over the course of my life
um
then
i'll just get permission from toby and
break the pledge like
it's not like this kind of crazy um
thing that i want to stick to like even
if the consequences were going to be
worse right it's more just making a
clear commitment about this but i think
it will it will likely present some
interesting philosophical like slide
rule equations because for example
you know what if an opportunity arises
for you to travel to some place but
there isn't you know where you could
potentially
uh do some good but there isn't money to
get you there and that would put you
over your budget you know is it more
important for you to
as a sort of you know emblematic message
to the world to hold true to your pledge
or would it be more
positively beneficial for the world for
you to break the pledge and then go
someplace that costs money to get to to
enact the good yeah i think i mean
uh yeah like i say i'm not doing this
for reasons of asceticism uh i think you
know the ultimate justification for
doing all this is the outcomes you
produce in the world and so in a case
like that i'd um
uh yeah think of it as a business
expense
um not count it as so that would come
out of the other side of the equation
yeah that's right yeah uh
and but i want to be kind of clear and
transparent about that so
uh yeah because it's just
if it means that i'm just handcuffing
myself in certain cases when i could do
more good then right that's exactly
against the spirit of why i'm doing this
okay so you make this pledge which then
you know bifurcates your income but then
you're presented with this
uh very practical real world question
which is also a philosophical question
which is how to allocate
this money and when we kind of look at
altruism
it seems to me that
that that you know that's basically
potential energy right and that
potential energy can be expended through
finances
through or through time right is that
essentially yeah correct yeah so
so now you have uh you know you have a
finite amount of time and you have this
other kind of allocated
cash reserve
and then it becomes an issue of like how
how is this going out into the world
into the best way which then you you run
that through your philosophical
brain and and perform that calculus and
really your life's work is an expression
of that it's like an ongoing expression
of how to apply a more scientific method
to
um to the allocation of this potential
energy so that it enacts the most you
know quote unquote
good right so if we're going to explore
that we should probably first talk about
like what is good you know like how are
you defining good yeah terrific so
that's exactly like it's early 2009 and
toby and i even on a low estimate over
the course of our lives are going to
give a million pounds one and a half
million dollars and the question's just
okay well
this is a big spending decision how are
we going to use that as well as possible
and so for that defining good obviously
it's contested but i think
one thing that um
all
kind of plausible model views agree on
is at least part of the truth
is
about what makes for the good outcome
is the sum total of improvements to
people's lives so if i can extend your
life if you're happy that's
you know improving the qual that's
improving your life if i can increase
the quality of your life while you're
live
uh that's improving your life as well
and
that's what i take the core of altruism
to be it's just improving other people's
lives and if you can improve
more people's lives that's better if you
can improve people's lives by greater
than amount
um that's better too and there might be
other things that go into good outcomes
like art for its own sake and knowledge
for its own sake um the preservation of
the natural environment for its own sake
not just in terms of how those things
translate into improvements in people's
lives
but there's at least one thing that
everyone can agree on which is that
just making people suffer less making
people happier is a good thing to do
right and that's what i tend to focus on
right right so so you have this
experience as a chugger yeah and and uh
you know are getting you they're saying
talk to the hand and you're realizing
uh
this is a broken system like trying to
get people to
act uh you know in an altruistic way
whether logically or emotionally is is
is a hurdle and then your focus sort of
looks at
you know kind of the corporate
environment of giving in general and
also realizing that that is broken like
there's got to be a better way
uh
to give to help to be altruistic so you
know let's let's look let's look at that
for a minute like you know what is the
what is the culture what is the
environment of
charity and giving and why is it broken
yeah okay so yeah there were two
differences one is that
a move from just thinking of charity is
this thing you do a couple of pounds a
couple of dollars a month and actually
taking it seriously making it part of a
significant part of your life
so that's one aspect but then the second
is
thinking about outcomes with respect to
charity um rather than having this
donor-centric philanthropy where you
give to the causes you personally feel
connected with or personally feel
passionate about instead thinking well
what are the charities that are gonna
have the best outcomes that are gonna do
the most good
measured in terms of improvements to
people's lives
and i think most people would think oh
well that's just an impossible question
you can't answer it
but actually there's a large body of
research from health and development
economics that can help you to answer
that question and that research was
primarily designed to advise developing
world governments and how they could
best spend their scarce resources
but exactly the same research could be
used to advise
us on how we should spend our scarce
resources when giving philanthropically
um
and they came up with a metric called a
quali or quality adjusted life year
which is just a way of measuring these
two ways of benefiting someone extending
their life or include improving the
quality of life
that someone has while they are alive
and using that metric
you can look at all sorts of different
health programs treatment for hiv aids
or condom distribution
um
or distributing bed nets or providing
deworming
uh all sorts of things and look at and
assess them and compare them in terms of
the impact they have in people's lives
and then you can pick the best the one
that has the biggest improvements right
so so essentially taking emotion out of
it
to some certain summits right yeah and
and you know as i'm kind of grappling
with that um i can't help but think
that you know giving is inherently very
it's a very emotional act for a lot of
people right it's it's people gravitate
towards the causes that they feel
personally connected to
so in some respect you're saying
that's fine
but
that's not a great way of
going about it yeah so an analogy is
maybe with being a doctor so
uh
if you're a doctor then you know you
might want to say oh caring and caring
for the sick is an inherently emotional
enterprise you don't want to take the
emotion out of that
but if you're a professional doctor and
you're um doing that all day every day
and having to make hard decisions about
who you're helping who you're not
engaging into the urge and so on you
simply have to have a certain level of
de detachment about that
uh because otherwise you're gonna
make bad tradeoffs you're going to be
too taken by
you know something you feel very
sympathetic towards um or just whoever's
right in front of you rather than
thinking okay what's actually the best
decision i could be making
and so obviously there's still an
underlying emotion there like the reason
people become doctors is because they
want to help other people right
similarly the reason we want to give is
you know it's an emotional lie of saying
we
uh
you know want to combat the big problems
in the world but then that needs to be
guided by the ability to reason our
ability to but isn't the first hurdle
getting people to actually get into
that that place of willingness to give
then it becomes about how you allocate
that right but if you're if you're
pulling that emotional aspect out of it
you know aren't you sort of
isn't that going to have a deleterious
impact on the total amount of giving you
know what i mean like it's a
psychological thing right if you're if
you're saying like the guy who feels
strongly about a certain cause and then
he's told well take a motion out of it
you know and then he's like well i'm
just not going to give you know what i
mean as opposed to all right i'll
channel this enthusiasm in a different
direction about something that i
don't necessarily care as much about
yes is that factored into how you yeah i
mean so if that was true that we were
just destroying people's
intentions do good that would definitely
be a bad outcome i would not be
effective altruism that would not be
effective autism uh
but i think there's a couple of things
to say firstly
in terms of whether we should be trying
to get people to give more to give more
effectively um i think there's a couple
of reasons to push and giving more
effectively one is this that there's
already so many people trying to get
others to give more huge focus on it
well there's not very much on
effectiveness
and second is that
the difference you can make is much
larger so maybe you get someone to give
10 times as much if you're really
successful at getting someone to give
more
but if you get someone to give more
effectively you could easily get them to
do 100 times as much good with their
donations
um right so you have this kind of
interesting example uh that i've heard
you talk about before
uh which is the is it books for africa
versus the the deworming program so so
to kind of play that out um let's say
you're you're passionate about literacy
right and so your instinct is to give to
this organization that is providing
books for
uh impoverished african children and the
idea there of course is that more books
is better this will this will improve
literacy and classroom attendance and
the like right but what's the actuality
of that yeah so you'd think obviously
giving books is a good thing in terms of
improving educational outcomes but when
tested
it's actually
i mean the evidence is very mixed at
best um seems like
distributing books at least in the
absence of teacher training has no
benefit
in terms of educational outcomes which
is very surprising but that's what the
data says
right so
so and the the sort of counter-intuitive
example that you used was
um that these they found out that a big
reason that classroom attendance was
falling off was because a lot of the
kids had worms right so yeah so actually
channeling that money towards deworming
programs and getting these kids healthy
improved attendance which in turn i
would assume enhances literacy so if
you're interested in supporting literacy
your money would have been better spent
funding these deworming
charitable organizations right yeah
that's right if you want to improve
educational outcomes if you want to
improve life outcomes deworming is one
of the best things in this part of the
world in this part in sub-saharan africa
that's right and in india
and that's not something you'd ever
think of because
um you know no one's had uh these sorts
of intestinal worms in
the u.s since the 50s they were
eradicated
so we don't even know about them whereas
everyone can
uh understand the idea of giving a book
it's easily understandable right and d
worming is also it's not a very sexy
intervention it's um it's kind of gross
it's not the sort of thing you want to
think about very much
so uh so when do you found giving what
we can so this is your first non-profit
yeah that was 14th of november 2009
right
12 years old
yeah just at the room
uh i guess i was 22 at that time
and
that initially i mean it was a small
affair there was 23 people who'd taken
the pledge at the time
and the first party
yeah many of them were my friends yeah
uh and
i was basically going there and talking
to people
uh
and you know the launch event was like a
fairly small gathering right um
but there was
an immense amount of attention and
interest
we were the most popular
news story in the uk in the bbc how did
that happen did that just
organically occur or was there like a
tipping point moment that really voiced
it that on the public consciousness yeah
i mean we talked to the university press
office at oxford and they just submitted
a press release and people found the
story i mean this was especially around
toby the co-founder uh of his pledge to
give everything about 20 000 pounds
intensely interesting and it was like
the feel-good news story of the day
and
it got on the bbc and then after that
point got a very large
amount of media attention from other
sources as well around the world in fact
um and that meant that giving what we
can became a bit of a light lightning of
odds for people who'd had similar ideas
but hadn't really acted on them all
around the world and so
did that predate kind of formalizing
this
school of thought called effective
altruism or did these sort of coincide
yeah it predated it um
for sure uh we came up with the term
effective altruism in
late 2010 or maybe early 2011.
simply because by that point we'd
realized that there was this
key idea um
combining doing more good and doing it
more effectively and we didn't really
have a name we've used so many different
things smart giving optimal
philanthropy you didn't think about
calling uh giving what we can
chugger.com and chugga.com
effective chugging yes uh thankfully we
didn't
but we had been referring to
you know people that we would now call
effective outfists so members of the
effective altitude community we were
calling them super hardcore do-gooders
which is a tongue-in-cheek word but yeah
we definitely needed to move beyond it
so you go from 23 and then what was that
growth curve like um approximately
doubling every year so we now have well
over a thousand members right um
including some people who've you know
given 50 90 of their incomes wow 90
yeah in some cases those must be rich
dudes i mean the person i'm thinking of
he's giving about 100 million dollars um
which is about 90 that's amazing yeah so
before we kind of explore that a little
bit further i want to get it because i
would imagine then with all these people
giving pledges that's what gives birth
to this idea of all right so how to best
allocate this right it becomes the next
sort of thing that you're going to have
to answer to and explore but before we
get into that you know i kind of want to
explore a little bit because you are
philosophy is your background and that's
what you've studied
the the relationship between
altruism
and happiness or maybe more aptly put
like self-satisfaction or
or or
you know a sense of purpose and
contentedness right and
you know we're in a you know
we're in a culture where that's not
particularly reinforced it's more about
you know accumulating the most material
possessions and creating security and
comfort around yourself
that's sort of dictated to us you know
via madison avenue or whatever the
television as being kind of the the most
well-trodden path to being a happy
contended person and despite the fact
that most people intellectually
understand that not to be the case we
still propel ourselves forward down that
down that road yeah i mean i think it's
all lies i think uh
uh you know i think marketing and
um advertising firms are just
continually lying to people about how
her best to be happy
uh and now i think
the reason for doing good isn't because
it'll make yourself happier um i think
uh you know the reason to try and help
others is because it's the right thing
to do and certainly when i was doing but
if you can appeal to people selfish you
know nature oh yeah then
and and get them to act like does the
and justify the means in that regard
like look do this you don't have to be
altruistic but this will make you a
happier person if you do this and you
get people to buy into that idea the
impact of that is still the same yeah
i'm perfectly happy with i mean i don't
yeah if people enjoy helping others and
they get a lot of satisfaction out of it
i think that's yeah they're a great
person um
the sort of person i want to be around
if someone's doing it solely as a matter
of duty um then okay that's a different
psychology but again the outcome i'm
right of that
and actually it's more and more evidence
is accumulating that
helping others is a really good way to
buy happiness and
um
buying material goods is a very bad way
of making of buying happiness and so we
looked into this quite a bit and we
actually think that
um
giving away even most of your income
is probably going to have not very much
impact at all on your happiness overall
because obviously you've got the loss
that you can't buy as much stuff for
yourself but the benefits of
uh then being able to
you know having the reward and
satisfaction of helping others right and
then but is that a first world problem
you know what i mean like i'm just
imagining somebody's listening to this
who's struggling to pay the bills they
have kids and they can barely you know
make their way to hear that could be
kind of jarring yeah i mean so it
depends exactly what um
income you're already on i mean i think
for you know people in the middle class
uh who are
uh in living in a rich country then i
think pretty much anyone can give 10
i mean importantly
basically every member of the
um of which countries like the u.s or uk
or in the which is ten percent of the
world's population
um
if you earn about fifty thousand dollars
after tax you'll know which is one
percent of the world's population
which makes it particularly acute if
you're living in the developed western
world in terms of the impact that you
can have because the disparity the
wealth the wealth disparity is so severe
in comparison to the developing world
that's right that's what does the work
is because
you just have something like
20 times 40 times as much
income as the very poorest people in the
world that means a dollar is just worth
so much more to them than it is to us
and it means that these very
simple
um
sorts of health programs like to save
using bed nets or deworming children um
just haven't been funded they're still
you're still able to spend money in that
way and yeah in my book i talk about
this is a hundred fold multiplier where
we have these good
uh theoretical reasons
and then it's backed up by the data for
thinking that you can benefit people in
the poorest countries a hundred times as
much as you can benefit yourself
um by spending money on yourself
and the analogy i give is like
imagine if you could buy a beer for
yourself was five dollars or you could
buy it for someone else for five cents
you know you'd say next lands on me like
right we'd find ourselves very very
generous and that's the situation within
all the time
the problem though is that
it's not in our consciousness right it's
just you know uh
you know it's
we're not aware we don't really think
about it because it's so far away and we
feel like it doesn't impact our lives
yeah that's the hurdle right
uh yeah that's definitely a big hurdle
and when it does it feels
alien it feels other i think often
the presentation has been um
very bad of just
you know
pot-bellied children starving with you
know flies in their faces and
uh we just glaze over and you of course
you glaze over you feel um put off you
feel like you're being emotionally
manipulated
far better to convey
you know in sub-saharan africa there's
incredibly rich vibrant cultures with
people who are just actually you know
they are pretty happy like a lot of the
time but then get sick in ways that
could be you know they're people that
you could be
would be very close friends with if you
happen to know them
um if you happen to live there and
illnesses that could be easily treated
or averted through some pretty basic
simple actions yeah that's right right
um and it's not like this you need this
deep emotional
um
uh appeal it's just almost common sense
that right you should be funding
something well i want to take a little
bit of a left turn here because it just
you you brought up something that i've
been thinking a lot about which is
uh
this advent of
conscious capitalism would have sort of
become a zeitgeisty kind of thing in our
culture
right everything from like tom shoes to
warby parker like all of these companies
are realizing
that the best way of doing business is
to allocate a portion of their
revenue towards a charitable cause
and
and in looking at that like i'm
interested in parsing out like
what aspect of that is truly effective
in terms of outcomes which is what
you're interested in versus marketing
hype right because it's good business to
make people feel good about buying your
product yeah and i had um
i interviewed daniel pinchback for the
podcast last winter i don't know if you
know who he is but
he spends a lot of time thinking about
these kinds of things and he was like
i think it's bs you know i think it's bs
it's marketing yeah spin and that's not
to say that you know if that money ends
up in a good place and does some good
for some people that's fine but what it
does
is it makes people feel good about
buying this product creates creates
brand loyalty
right
and i'm wondering
whether you think that that then
prevents people from exercising that
altruism in a more effective way because
they say well i buy tom's shoes oh yeah
yeah so i don't need to give to this
charity because i'm see my shoes like
that i was able to donate shoes to
somebody else and and you know what
truly is the impact of that is that
making a positive difference okay so
they fit yeah so i feel um deep and i'm
not i'm not bashing tom shoes like i i
like taunt you know i like that company
i just it was the first thing that came
to mind yeah uh although tom shoes is a
good example there have been studies of
the pokemon and
um
kids like the shoes but it doesn't make
much of a difference in terms of
education outcomes or any other outcomes
you can try to put shoes on their feet
is that i mean that's not a bad thing i
mean it's not a bad thing but you could
do better things i mean in the initial
story where
uh the founders who saw these children i
know they didn't even have shoes they
just they didn't like wearing shoes
that's why they weren't wearing shoes um
uh
so they're gonna get in trouble now i
might get into the photo
but um so i kind of feel ambivalent and
one that i think that really could work
but then it seems to be often
misimplemented i think i agree that very
large slaves with us are bs especially
within corporate social responsibility
the reason behind it is marketing and pr
not an honest desire to do good and then
i'm really pleased you mentioned so what
psychologists call a model licensing
effect
where
you doing one good deed especially if
it's a very public good deed so we're
being able to wear a pair of shoes or
something else at least shows off that
you've done this good thing
depending on the attitude with which
you're going into this act it can make
you do fewer good deeds um elsewhere
that presupposes that you have a finite
amount of altruism that you're willing
to expend yeah so you can imagine two
peop two different reasons why people
might want to do an altistic act one is
like this honest deep commitment to
wanting to do good um and some people
have that attitude i believe
another though is just you want to not
get criticized you want to show yourself
to be a good person so no one's going to
judge you
and if you're doing that then if you can
do something very salient that
very clearly demonstrates you this good
person then you don't need to do other
things as much right um
and so in that way it could even be
getting people to very publicly do small
like a small good thing can in fact be
harmful it risks being harmful i talked
about this a little bit with the i think
psychologically yeah i want to ask you
about that but i think but what about
the idea that if you do something good
it makes you feel good and then you want
to do more good yeah isn't that the
counter point to that so yeah that's the
kind of point and that can happen as
well so in the literature there's just
mixed you can get both effects
and
it i think depends on
how is this being presented and what's
the attitude that someone is coming in
so are they thinking oh i'm doing my bit
which i think is a very toxic phase
uh if so then you're going to get the
model licensing effect if instead it's
considered like okay well this is your
first step in a path to making this
thing right really core part of your
identity extreme perhaps follow-up right
right right interesting i mean
extrapolating on the this model
licensing idea there's a there's a very
interesting um kind of analogous
uh
idea in
the kind of animal rights vegan world
right now there's a guy called gary
francione who's a professor of law
rutgers
and he's always butting heads with pete
singer
because pete singer is somebody who kind
of
would say that incremental change is
good right and gary's taking a very kind
of adamant hard-line approach like
you're you either are or you are not
like you're either an animal right
you're either vegan or you're not you
can't like have it both ways and he uses
this interesting example that's kind of
apropos to what we're talking about
um in that we're in this period now
where where uh it's suddenly very
popular to
eat grass-fed meat right and like
sustainably raised quote unquote
ethically harvested
and the impact of this according to gary
is negative in the sense that it's
basically making people feel better
about making in
you know
in his mind an inhumane choice so it's
reinforcing
the meat eaters habit
as opposed so like when you see these
posters in whole foods where you see the
farmers and everyone looks happy and the
cows look happy and when you go and buy
your burger you don't feel that guilt
that maybe you would feel otherwise so
it's actually entrenching the behavior
that you know he would like to see
overcome you know what i mean yeah
there's something similar about that i
think yeah so i mean again on that issue
in particular it's something i feel
ambivalent about and
i think ultimately i'd
i'm happy on the
you know i'd endorse the incremental
view at least if it's properly applied
because just because i think the vast
majority of animal suffering
occurs on
by um is suffered by chickens and
factory farms just if you could run
through the numbers and you look at the
conditions of different
animals
uh so maybe i think that like yeah uh
yeah no i hear i hear you're saying we
gotta get you off the dairy though oh
yeah
we'll talk about it yeah i'm perfectly
happy to have a discussion about that
uh
but then
yeah this is the same thing with um
giving to charity as well
um
you know perhaps people should be taking
the hard line approach
uh i think in our own experience you
know so peter singer was making these
arguments that were very hard lined
saying you know if you're looking at the
morality of the situation you should
give everything until
uh
you are
you know you know living the same living
on the same level of income as the
people you're trying to help so you
should basically be giving away all of
your income and does he walk that walk
himself uh he gives about 35 40 of his
income um which was very significant
given uh
you know he was the only person doing
this he was kind of
lone ranger at the time and now you know
me and toby and others like to see
ourselves as kind of out doing him
the next innovation
um
but interestingly not that many people
seem to act on it the uptick really came
and people really acting in these
arguments in 2009 with me and toby and
then everything and then the others and
giving what we can saying presenting it
in this different way right saying look
okay well and i honestly believe this
even if it weren't a moral obligation
it's still this amazing opportunity like
it's just part of your own values like
think about what it means to live a good
life you have these opportunities to you
know be the person who like
runs into a burning building and saves a
child's life truly aligning your actions
with your value system yeah exactly like
having that co
you know coherence
is really kind of a beautiful thing yeah
that's right and
that's the kind of primary message we
put forward because that's true whether
or not you believe it's a moral
obligation and it's something that gets
people a lot more excited right and i
feel like actually the same thing
happens with vegetarianism and veganism
you know there's a very large
uptake in
people becoming vegetarian or vegan on
health grounds
and within the animal welfare community
there's debate about that because
you know they think maybe people are
doing the right thing but for the wrong
reasons right yeah how important is
motivation yeah and i ultimately think
that normally people's beliefs follow
their behavior so i think if you can get
people acting the right way then they'll
start to believe that like things as
well well yeah i mean that's been my
exam that's been my experience i mean
had you you know i've been hearing
animal rights activists talk my whole
life and it had zero impact on me and
then i had a you know a personal
situation that compelled me to entertain
it in a health context i embraced that
it was positive in my life and then it's
evolved so now i'm much more interested
in the environmental implications and
the ethical implications of these
choices that we make and you know it's
my version of what you're doing in the
sense that i have aligned my my choices
in this regard with my value system and
yeah it's a good feeling right
um but i think in terms of trying to
you know my responsibility as a
spokesperson for this in the same way
that you're a spokespers person for your
cause is how do you effectively
communicate people in order to
um effectuate
the change that you're looking for right
and there's different strategies for
that you know some people will hammer
people over the head or moralize or
judge yeah and you know my approach has
always been to create you know a very
um
you know welcome mat for people where
they feel comfortable asking the right
questions and you know allowing people
to have that incremental change because
for me it didn't happen overnight and i
think for most people it doesn't and for
the people that say they got hit with a
lightning bolt and they changed
overnight i think for
certainly i'm sure there's people out
there that that happen to but i think
you know for by and large for most
people it's a gradual evolution and you
have to give people space to grow into
that yeah and you can
yeah and that's why i think
uh you know people like you are all
models for this because
a lot of the reasons why people might
think oh i'm not going to become
vegetarian or vegan there's oh well what
will happen to my health or my fitness
or
oh i'm going to become you know have a
negative stereotype of what that
involves and so if there are people who
are like yeah i'm running ultra
madison's um you know at the peak
performance and being vegan as well
right and you're saying
i'm giving away most of my money and i'm
actually happy and i'm productive and
i'm doing all these interesting things
and i feel good about what i do and i'm
i'm impacting other people yeah i mean
my life has gone far better after taking
that pledge than it would have otherwise
been i'd have been i'd still be i'd be
sitting in a library um
some challenges though like i'd really
like to get that thing but
like what's been the hardest part
yeah that's a good question
um
i mean i think
on the money side of things uh
actually very little i mean i just
there's you know i've never moved
because i was a student then a grad
student so i never had i've never gone
downwards i've never gotten used to a
higher level of earnings
um maybe the harder thing was like like
the amount of time
you know because i'm trying to spend my
time as well as possible and that means
just working very hard
on my research on the non-profits i
co-founded as well um
and maybe i could have taken a few more
weekends over the last
six years but
all right so let's get into
the
the calculus
that you've kind of developed to
evaluate
um
you know the charitable options that are
available like what are the
qualifications in your mind when you
look at these organizations in terms of
trying to come up with you know the best
most effective channel for
your funds or for somebody's funds out
there who's listening
yeah so i think the three
key questions when thinking about
charitable giving
the first is the program that the
charity works on
the second is how well executed um
the charity implements the program and
then third is just where they can
actually usefully use more money
and the first one is almost always
neglected
people think oh you just can't compare
across different programs but that's not
really true economists have been using
tools to be able to do that
like the quality adjusted life year that
i mentioned before that's cashing out
the different programs in terms of by
how much they're improving people's
lives
um
and so there's a large body of you know
academic research that can help you
answer that question
and because uh
and at least in terms of
you know benefiting present day humans
uh
focusing your energy like focusing your
resources on
especially areas in global health to
benefit the very poorest people tend to
be the best ways of doing that
i think the conventional you know sort
of average person looks at this and
and they say well you know how much
overhead is there you know like oh all
this money's going to overhead i don't
want to support that and you have kind
of an interesting yeah very logical
perspective on that yeah so i think this
is just a junk metric i think it's just
so
uh
like it's very confused and i'm
annoyed it's been so widely promoted
because if you've got a lousy charity
it's gonna stay a lousy charity even if
you've got zero percent overhead so the
u.s golf association is a charity but
uh is that going to do as much good as
um
giving to bed nets uh clearly not even
if it had zero percent overhead and as
an analogy think about if you're buying
a product for yourself you're kind of
looking to buy a mac or a nit dell
laptop
what you know would you look at how much
the ceos are paid would you look at how
much money is spent on overhead and or
administration versus actual design
building of the products no
you just look at how much is these two
products cost and how good is the
product
and we should think in just the same way
uh for charities
with a certain amount of money that
you're giving to the charity what's the
outcome this charity is producing if it
needs to spend more than overhead
overhead to produce a better outcome
then that's great
we should be placing it for doing right
maybe uh you know maybe uh paying a ceo
quite a bit of money like a really good
ceo can come in and effectuate the most
good would be a prudent business
decision yeah that's right um it's
almost uh it's kind of a selfish
emotional thing because we want as a
giver we want to feel connected to the
money that we're donating right so when
you when it's going towards overhead or
rent we don't feel like our contribution
is actually getting to the person who
needs it right but on some level that's
sort of
selfish like we want we want to like see
the you know the hand of the that's
eating the food you know what i mean
like even if in the in the meta sense
it's effectuating the most change
it's not giving us that that warm fuzzy
feeling yeah right
and i think there's a
kind of pure botanical element as well a
little bit which is that
you know ngo workers should be not
taking salaries or taking very low
salaries
even if that's counterproductive because
they're in this world and it's all about
it's all about yeah giving back so how
dare you that's right but then if it's
counterproductive then why do we think
this yeah but i think it you know in
contrast to that we are in a time now
where especially young people are
demanding more and more transparency in
the in the for-profit sector and in the
nonprofit sector and you see this in the
nonprofit sector in the sense that you
know these these organizations are
creating that transparency like track
your dollar and you can see exactly
where it goes and and da da da da da and
i think that that's a you know that's a
good thing whether you know that's
better than not having that oh yes i
think transparency is uh terrific and
that kind of relates to the second
question is how well is the
organization
implementing one of these programs uh
and in particular
um
is it being honest with respect to the
mistakes it's making so one of the
charities that i think does the most
good is uh
uh give directly and it's a very simple
program just transfers transfers cash
directly to
some of the poorest people in the world
living in kenya
and
one their most exceptionally transparent
organization they even have update
charts that update weekly
on what proportion of
uh households has to pay a bribe in
order to receive the transfer oh my god
and the answer is like kind of two or
three percent um and almost no charity
would ever do that because all charities
always have to pretend that everything's
perfect all the time that's never true
zero times
um and so a charity that's fairly honest
about the obstacles it's facing that's a
very good sign in fact
um
when oxfam published a whole bunch of
studies they'd taken showing that many
of the programs actually weren't having
an impact i thought more of the rocks
i'm not less
and
so yeah this sort of very great
transparency is a very good sign
also just whether is the
uh organization you know being led by
really good people
um
does it is it doing monitoring and
evaluation or even kind of trials of its
own
uh of its own programs and how much does
it need your money right like like i'm
thinking about what happened with the
red cross and katrina yeah where there
were massive amounts of cash you know
getting poured out and and and it not
getting you know allocated it's probably
the most famous example though yeah
yeah that's like misallocation
yeah so that's the final question is
about what i call room for more funding
which is even if a charity is doing
terrific work
um and has done in the past you don't
know that addition doesn't necessarily
follow additional donations are going to
be as well used so
an example of this is a polio
immunization vaccination
uh incredibly effective program um
should
you know definitely put money towards it
except that it's already fully funded by
the gates foundation
um additional money going to that just
isn't actually going to have much of a
difference
and the same is often to do with
disaster relief
because it's so well publicized
uh disaster natural disasters get a huge
amount more funding than what i'd call
ongoing natural disasters like deaths
from
malaria tuberculosis
where i think you can have a much larger
impact
so
how do we make this decision
right like how do we how do we find out
like is this the idea behind
you know the nonprofit that you started
like if somebody's listening like i have
x amount of dollars to give and i want
to allocate it best but i don't even
know where to begin yeah well then i
think the best thing to do is to go on
to
uh the website of an organization that i
didn't found but um i support very
strongly called givewell so it's
giveworld.org and
you know they've done the hard work of
doing extraordinarily in-depth
um
research to work out what are these
charities that do the very most good
right and they kind of started these
guys started kind of with a similar
premise as you right like they were like
but they were like investment bankers
trying to figure out like all right
where they wanted to make this pledge
but they couldn't figure out where it
should best go yeah looks like they were
working for the hedge fund bridgewater
and they were giving some of their money
and thinking well i want to keep this
like any other purchasing decision i
want to get my biggest bang for buck
and they started trying to talk to
charities and just finding they can get
even what they thought of as the very
most basic information just
what will my money actually do do you
have any evidence behind this
by this program why are you choosing
this on anything else
in fact one charity that
uh the now ceo holden karnovsky spoke
with
was so confused by this that they phoned
bridgewater to kind of get him fired um
because they thought that he must be a
spy for a different charity oh wow and
that could be the only motivation he'd
have asking questions do some of the
charities try to lobby to get on these
lists i mean i would imagine it's
impactful to their bottom line right um
yeah i mean we get so giving what we can
has their commended charities as well
that often relies very heavily on
giftworld's research but sometimes
differs
uh and yeah we get a ton of people
contacting us you know trying to make
the case right um i mean it's never you
know we just have our own independent
research and aren't affected by that
right um
because yeah i mean it's a matter of
millions of dollars going to these
charities right and in kind of running
this calculus i mean you're
you know there's only
i would imagine so much
scientific method like you're taking
philosophical precepts you're trying to
apply
logic
and math to try to come up with the best
options for people
but isn't it more complicated i mean we
have psychology that plays into this
and then there's certain
intangibles right like
what about uh
investing in
new technologies where you don't know
what's going to happen with that and
what about you know political forces
that are intervening that you have no
control over that could you know prevent
certain things from happening like yeah
how do you approach that or wrap your
head around that yeah so so far we've
just talked about these kind of more
easily quantifiable
uh programs that have short-term effects
like distributing bad nets for the
cancellation foundation deworming
children that are all kind of fall into
this 100x that's right idea that you
have but by no means do i think they're
definitely the best uses of money
because you could do things that are
really trying to make big systemic
change
and givewell are now looking into that
in conjunction with the foundation
called good ventures
uh these much kind of more
uncertain but potentially higher payoff
uh sorts of activities like you know
policy change immigration reform um
potentially better today deals
innovation as well biotech biotech yeah
exactly um biomedical research
and so even that first thing just
deciding whether you should fund bed
nets rather than direct cash transfers
involves a lot of judgment calls right
definitely not a hard science like right
so if you're sitting on ten thousand
dollars and you can say well i could
donate this to an organization that has
a one percent chance of of saving the
lives of a million people
or i could donate this money to an
organization that has a 100 percent
chance of
of saving the lives of 10 people
so philosophically this is a bit of a
moral dilemma right yeah i mean
so and they talk about this in doing it
better um
i introduce the idea of expected value
and so i'm pleased you took put numbers
out there because uh
then i can say well i think the way you
should work you should assess
decisions like this is to look at the
probability of success and how good
success would be and then you multiply
it all together so you said one percent
chance of a million lives
that's an expected 10 000 lives one
percent times a million and then he said
versus a guarantee of ten lives well
that's way less than a hundred and ten
thousand right and so i think
the way the best way to make decisions
in light of uncertainty like this is to
look at the probability multiply it by
the value of the success and then go
with what um
your decision scientists call the
expected value right right um and that
would mean in this case we actually i
think there would be a
kind of better answer which is to go
with
that one percent chance of saving a
million lives interesting and in the
research that you've done i mean you've
kind of come up with pretty concrete
numbers of the actual dollar amount that
it would take to
save a life or support a life yeah so
our best guess at the moment is
um
a donation of three and a half thousand
dollars to the against malaria
foundation will save a life
statistically when you say save a life
like that that's sort of an amorphous
term too right like what are we talking
about so what we're talking about is
three and a half thousand dollars will
put 600 bed nets um over the heads of
1200 children for two years
um
one of those children under five would
have died of malaria had you not done
that
um so that's precisely what we're
talking about right right right uh
and
sometimes people hear that and they're
like oh i thought it cost five dollars
to save a life and that's a shame that's
because chavities often give these very
optimistic numbers
but i think deep down people often don't
believe them whereas this is just
actually our kind of best guess even
taking into account all sorts of
different uncertainty
interesting all right so we've kind of
explored
the first metric of effective altruism
which is allocation of financial
resources but now we have time right so
how do we approach this and figure out
how to best allocate this resource great
and this is good yeah so this in the
story um
uh of how i was coming to these ideas
we're now moving from 2009 to 2011.
uh
and precisely i've been promoting this
idea of
cost-effective giving to charity i had
all these students coming to me and
saying okay well that's all great but
i've got this really big decision coming
up which is
what the hell should i do with my career
and they all ask me should i just try
and get rich and give it all away should
i work for a non-profit what should i do
and i was having to face this decision
as well um
uh should i stay as an academic should i
you know go and do something completely
different this is applied philosophy
it's a delightful opportunity to apply
your philosophy yeah exactly um
and in particular one of these people
who came to me and pressed quite
forcefully was ben todd
he had
the options of doing a phd in climate
physics or he could go into asset
management where he could donate a lot
and we gave
uh
what was intended to be a discussion
group turned into a lecturer which
turned into a series of lectures because
in that first lecture i think a third of
the audience changed their career plans
as a result of the talk and then we
thought okay this is a sufficiently
important set of concepts that and
completely lacking in the world like if
a young person wants to make a
difference in their lives using their
time
uh using the clear they have nowhere to
go for the device like the service will
just give them some
mediocre tips on how to make a nice
resume
and then um other the few online sites
like ethical careers will just say oh
work in the nonprofits they don't even
think
about other options and so we've set up
an organization called 80 000 hours
which is the number of hours you
typically work um in the course of your
life
where the idea is you know it's a big
deal it's worth in general when you make
a decision
you might want to spend one percent of
that time working out how to best spend
the other 99
right yeah you'd think so but not that
many people would spend
you know 800 hours uh 20 working weeks
you know just sitting down and thinking
okay what am i going to do with my life
right um
and
yeah so we now
so
it's really hard to figure out what
chavities are the best it's even harder
to figure out what cardio paths are the
best and obviously it's going to be a
lot more relative to the person
but we think
there's a lot of progress that can be
made at least relative to the status quo
so
the standard advice of if you want to do
good work for the charity
we think
is badly wrong in a few ways so one is
just that many challenges have no impact
when tested something like 75 of social
programs just don't make a difference at
all
uh second is that obviously there's
loads of good ways to do good
outside of the non-profit sector through
policy politics research
entrepreneurship and just you know the
activities of for-profit companies as
well
at least depending on the company
so it's again a very narrow approach but
then the third thing we think is just
this is also neglecting
uh what we think of as the best path to
really making a big difference which is
early on in your career where you just
don't have many skills maybe you've
come out of a good university but you
studied philosophy
doesn't have that much the kind of real
world application you should really be
thinking about leveling up you should be
thinking about making yourself better as
a person being more skilled
um in order to have a big impact later
on
and that might well mean working in a
for-profit company
or trying to work in some very elite
environment
and before then perhaps working for
non-profits
um and then the very final mistake i
think is that only thinks about the
impact you can have through your labor
rather than through your ability to
advocate so like martin luther king
didn't work for the chavity right he was
a
minister who's then able to advocate for
import this incredibly important cause
um all your ability to donate as well so
again bill gates didn't work for the
non-profit it's done a huge amount of
good i estimate he's saved more lives
than everyone in my home country of
scotland
and you know that was through his
ability to donate and there so there are
several paths to doing goods and where
to work out yeah for each person what's
the one that's gonna have the very
biggest impact well just the simple fact
that you're drawing attention to it and
mindfulness around these ideas at the
outset of a young person's career is
potent and powerful in its own right you
know what i mean like it's just the fact
that it's part of the discussion part of
the you know the mental decision making
process of entering your career but i
would imagine
you know it gets further complicated you
know we're living in more and more of a
independent contractor world it's not
that it's not the you know the world of
you get a career and that's where you
stay your whole life yeah it's like
people are having multiple careers and
doing many many different things so
you know many careers along the way and
and so i'm just thinking like how do you
i mean in terms of like providing a
service through 80 000 hours like you've
got to come up with some kind of
algorithm right
to provide these options for people to
explore i would imagine that's that's
the heavy lifting of of what you're
trying to do yeah well i think that's
exactly right and i think a big mistake
a lot of people make is thinking of
their choice as this all-or-nothing
decision
um
something you make when you're 22 and
then you have to stick with the rest of
your life
whereas really we think you should have
a kind of career model so you should
think of yourself like an ex
an experimental scientist or
investigative journalist or something
you have a hypothesis about what would
make for the good what is the right
career for you then you go and test it
and that's like a decision made over
like a year or two
and then if it doesn't work you can go
and do something else
and so the careers we often recommend
are those that give you a very large
base of options from which to go on to
other things and again that's often a
reason for not working in non-profits
it's hard to move from non-profits to
other fields
[Music]
whereas
if you get like an economics phd that
opens up a lot of doors um if you're
working in something like management
consulting or if you learn to code again
you're just opening up a lot of doors
and so we encourage people at least to
begin with to
work in these skill sets that can be
applicable in unforeseen ways later
exactly
implicit in all of this is you know
quite a bit of optimism right like
you're very you must be a very
optimistic guy to be even tackling this
problem to begin with
uh so how do you like sort of
communicate with people who are coming
from a different perspective i mean i
feel like
you know the massive culture feels very
disenfranchised they feel like their
vote doesn't count what's the point i'm
just gonna watch dancing with the stars
and eat my bag of cheetos and try to buy
the the best biggest screen tv that i
can and
go
thanks you guys can have an impact yeah
well i think there's a couple of things
so
in terms of pessimism
like with respect to the world and
progress um i think that's just not
unfounded i think not founded at all i
think of the last 200 years
we've just had the most amazing lies in
the standards of living of
um a large proportion of people in the
world and
so
you know efforts to then
um fight extreme poverty is just how to
continue winning in ways that we really
haven't done in the whole of human
history before
but then secondly in terms of actually
having an impact i just think it's not
borne out by the fact that you can't i
mean we've seen this over and over again
uh
you know if
again coming back just to charitable
spending if you spend your money in the
right way then just 10 can save hundreds
of lives over the course of your life
um that's absolutely huge and people say
i was just a lap in the bucket but
that's you know not really irrelevant
it's the size of the right you know you
actually
pulled 10 people out you know out of the
ocean who are drowning that would change
your life forever yeah exactly but we
just stay with you we don't feel
emotionally connected to it so it's not
the same experience but the but the
outcome is the same yeah exactly
um so i think in part of your in the way
that you communicate or try to like
you know sort of compel this change
there has to be a way to psychologic
psychologically like you know
create that bridge
right because
the psychology is the big part right
it's like catalyzing the act like
intellectually
you know it makes perfect sense it's
logical the philosophical basis for it
is sound the impact is is measurable
right but there is the psychological
barrier to taking the action yeah and i
think that's exactly right and
that's why kind of one of the things
we've done is built this community the
effects of autism community which is
just
um a community of
uh thousands of people around the world
who are just really excited about doing
good and doing it effectively as well
and
that allows you to get this kind of
positive reinforcement
um because if you
do start making like you know changes in
your life that are gonna do more good
for the world you've got a whole bunch
of people around you going yeah that's
amazing
and that's you know then suddenly your
peers are just kind of rewarding you um
being very positive about those sorts of
actions
and that's not tying yourself to the um
the beneficiaries of your
actions ultimately um
you're not being connected with the
children you're deworming but i've
actually found psychology is
psychologically it's just very powerful
as well like
uh i do find when i get up um
you know when i get up in the morning
and i'm feeling psyched about my work or
when i'm feeling like most rewarded by
the work i'm doing
it's mainly through
you know inspiring people to do more
goods and just
how excited they get by that
um rather than the you know the people
on the other side of the world that i'm
you know not as connected to right right
right yeah that's interesting yeah and i
think that's again been
really you know part of the reason for
the uptake of these ideas is that now
there's
you know it's a community it's a group
of people who are all together saying
look we're gonna write our lives in a
certain way well that that's the
advocacy aspect of what you're doing
though right it's not like your money is
going to deworming that's one aspect of
it but the advocacy in actually
catalyzing change in the people that
you're impacting you know perhaps on a
one by one basis
or by virtue of the talks that you're
giving there's a real sense of of
accomplishment there like that's making
a difference you know it's like you have
some resources going
to africa and the other resources are
pushing out in the other direction in a
different way through the kind of energy
that you're putting out there yeah um
yeah so i mean ultimately i'm hoping for
that
wide-scale societal shift where people
think very differently about
you know giving to charities not just
this nice thing to do but you know
altruism or attempting to help others
just
isn't you know i want people to think of
that as an obvious part of like
significant part of just what it means
to live a good life well you have to
make it cool you have to make it cool
cool to be altruistic i mean that's the
truth you know what i mean it's like
you have to make like i have like i
haven't i feel an obligation to make
being vegan cool
because people you're not going to line
it off so well well yeah but it's like
you're not going to get it's like you're
not going to get people to eat this food
if it doesn't taste good like it's got
to actually taste better than what
they're eating you know what i mean
that's how you
catalyze change that's how you attract
it so i feel like you're you know like
you're
this millennial you know what i mean who
has a very powerful message and it's
attractive because you have great energy
and you're optimistic
and and people want to they want to be
like you you know it's cool it's cool to
be altruistic and the more that you can
kind of infuse the message with with
that you know i feel like that's a
really powerful
route
yeah i think um you know and that's the
kind of message we want to convey again
emphasizing just this is awesome
opportunity it's actually a really
amazing way to live your life
um it's a way where you're not going to
find yourself um in middle age just
you're thinking well you know i've made
a ton of yeah but unless they've made a
ton of money but what does it all mean
you know you wouldn't think oh well you
know i saved ten thousand lives but like
what was the point this
doesn't really make sense yeah yeah
what about i mean have do you account
for
uh personal development like
you know the buddha would say that
the best way to improve the world is to
improve yourself you know what i mean
like you can't help others until you
help yourself so
uh for example you know time spent on
self-help or meditation or mindfulness
practices or the time that i spend each
day when i get up and i go running or i
go to the pool
would seemingly not kind of be
applicable to this calculus of giving
back but i feel like it's absolutely
crucial to me
in order to be the best version of who i
am so that i am available for the rest
of it yeah no i think that's totally
right i mean
if you're trying to do a lot of good
then
improving your ability to do that is
incredibly important i mean at the
extreme
uh
if you're you know reckless and
get hit by a card or something because
you're not crossing the load or not
wearing your seat belt and killed in a
car crash all the good you do in the
course of your life
it's not going to matter right um and so
i think you know the time i spend at the
gym anytime i'm spending meditating you
know that's the most effective use of
the time in the day
because that enhances everything else
right and uh
yeah that's why there's often quite a
bit of overlap or interest from the
effective autism community also in the
kind of productivity personal
development
um life hacking rationality uh
communities as well because
you know we've got this aim just trying
to help others as much as possible part
of that means leveling yourself up means
um being a better person um and actually
i found that
you know one of the surprising ways i
wouldn't have anticipated that this has
benefited myself
is that now you've got this big reason
to actually like get out of bed and go
to the gym yeah yeah it's because you're
not just benefit it's not just so that
you can yourself have a better life but
it's actually because
um you're infused with yeah you're
infused with a sense of purpose that's
right yeah yeah and there's nothing more
powerful than that yeah really
all right let's talk a little bit about
some of the controversy swirling around
some of your ideas sure not a fan of the
ice bucket challenge
so
i got you into a little trouble it got
me into trouble yeah um let's break that
down i didn't uh so that was unexpected
i bought that article quite quickly oh
come on professor everybody love the ice
bucket challenge
why be a hater and then i was it was
glumpy article about it
so i wanted
yeah i was making a couple of points so
one as we've talked about was this
ethical licensing uh the worry that
the ice bucket challenge was the most
extreme like this um where it's very
public
uh you know you're pouring a bucket lice
over your head
so very salient action going out to all
of your facebook friends so you can
really demonstrate how altruistic you
are
uh
and then donating
i think what ended up being on average
relatively small amounts of money like
tens of dollars or something i think it
was meant to be a hundred dollars but
people would often donate less right i
mean aggregate what did they raise like
three million no in the advocate they
raised a hundred million 100 million
yeah
so you're not really a hater well so
that'll come to the second point is then
just
so that was the first thing is you've
got to you've got to think
of that 100 million how much would have
been donated to other charities what are
the other kind of effects
um and all i wanted to say is just well
we need to think before we say kind of
lavishing plays on this
phenomenon we need to have an assessment
of that in an estimate right let's
dissect it and figure out exactly what
happened and what yeah that's fine
because it's just it's not obvious that
it's
net positive i mean we always say oh
it's 100 million raised for charity but
it's 100 million raised and how much
taken from other charities
so i mean the amount of funding
that goes to charities or percentage
that america can spend on charitable
giving is pretty constant over time
which suggests that additional
fund-raising efforts are maybe just
eating away at
others all right but hold on a second i
mean i feel like this was you know
because it was a viral internet moment
that it must have
you know i i don't know but i would
assume that it must have inspired people
who ordinarily don't give
to
to give in the moment because they were
caught up in the excitement of this so
you're you're you're adopting kind of a
zero-sum game approach where this is
taking money away from other charities
but you could make that argument with
respect to any giving right anytime you
give that's money that didn't go
somewhere else
yeah or any big fundraising campaign and
i think it just is true um that whenever
you're raising money then to some extent
i don't think a hundred percent but to
some extent that's taking money away
from other but if you're watching
benedict cumberbatch get his you know
like get ice on his head
you know i'm sure there were people who
just spontaneously gave ten dollars who
weren't previously you know thinking
about giving money and just did it in
the moment yeah i'm sure there was
something and so you're assuming that
that had an impact on their later giving
but i'm it's not so sure that that's
valid is it yeah so the idea is that it
impacted some people's later giving and
there is some evidence for thinking
that's the case like the fact that
people's giving on average just doesn't
seem to change um
kind of year on year just remains about
two percent and so i don't think all of
the hundred million dollars would have
been donated somewhere else
um
from kind of so given what we can for
example we've raised about 450 million
dollars of pledge donations
um
and we ask people like how much do you
think you would have been giving
otherwise
and we estimate it's about 50 percent
right but that's that's unreliable
information coming back to you though oh
yeah that's right yeah yeah it might
sort of anecdotally yeah that's right it
might be too high it might be too low
but it's also just what you'd expect
is that a certain percentage of money is
going to be
donated anyway whenever you're doing a
fundraising campaign
but crucially that means and this takes
us to the second issue is that we simply
have to ask the question of how
effective is the als association
compared to other charities compared to
the average charity
because
if the als association is significantly
less effective than
charities on average then if you're
doing two things one is that you're
raising say
50 million from
just out of nowhere would have been
spent on ice cream or something and 50
million that would have gone from other
charities if those other charities are
much more effective than the als
foundation on average then you could be
net harmful for that reason
and
i think there's
some arguments for thinking that so
using this method of quality adjusted
life here i think
the estimates that it costs about 200
000
via als treatment um
uh
just to look after someone for the year
um who's suffering from als
uh you know with that same money you
could save the lives of
uh
tens of thousands of people i think um
but not quite thousands of people
um
and so
yeah so we just at least and again i
didn't want to come down as a conclusion
we at least have to ask that question
and then in particular you know when a
charity is getting a hundred million
dollars
is that like final million dollars gonna
be spent as well as the first million
dollars it's very unlikely especially
when it's income is increasing 50-fold
yeah explain that idea a little bit yeah
so um
this is the idea of
thinking on the margin is what
economists do it but the idea that just
things have diminishing returns so you
have your first coffee in the morning
and that you know makes you feel really
good kind of perks you up
um but if you have to drink three or
four then you start to feel kind of sick
you know seconds less good and in
general just whenever
everything has diminishing returns so
you spend your money in the best way
that you can
then when you have more money you have
to you've already used up that
opportunity you can
not spend it as well
and so for something like
an organization that's getting a vast
influx of funds
it's going to not know
firstly it might just struggle to spend
the money well at all because it's just
unprecedented it's never even thought
about how to spend money in this way
then the second is that even if it does
have a good plan it's simply not going
to be able to spend it as well
um
as it spends the initial
use of funds because right so in other
words let's say
the final 10 million dollars
als gets 90 the final 10 goes somewhere
else that is in much more dire need of
that money
the the sort of impact in a meta sense
is much more profound
yeah that yeah that's exactly right
um
and i think this relates to healthcare
you know philanthropic spending on
healthcare in general
uh
something like
um
you're going to do a lot more good by
funding
malaria treatment um rather than or
prevention worth and something to do
with
uh cancer prevention of treatment uh
because
you're giving to countries where
people are so much poorer that
additional money makes a much bigger
difference and so much less money is
already spent on malaria that the lowest
hanging opportunity the ease the best
opportunities have still not been taken
whereas planet cancer is just like a
really hard problem but by taking this
like very you know economic
dispassionate approach to this you're
draining all the fun out of it right so
the als challenge was fun and it goes
back to what we were talking about about
making it cool right so it was cool to
do that yeah people were making fun
videos
and and and i think an intangible in
your equation is the long-term impact of
people being excited about campaigns
that that you know get them to
reach for their wallets yeah right so
that maybe
maybe that campaign has created more
people interested in altruism than would
have existed otherwise
yeah so that's the
that's the kind of alternative so again
we were talking about ethical licensing
versus what psychologists are called
foot in the door the kind of first step
and
again i'd be really in favor of that if
we can just kind of raise the altruism
water line of a whole society that would
be a fantastic thing to do right that
could potentially overcome uh you know
whatever downside occurred in your
perspective of as a result of the ice
bucket challenge right yeah yeah
potentially um
but it seems to me like it wasn't
designed i mean it wasn't designed at
all it's just this viral phenomenon um
right just
yeah just have him but i think somebody
had a fun idea
of doing something and it spread virally
but it's not dissimilar from you know
the skydiving example that you've you
know cited in the past these like this
you know creating fun activities around
giving which inherently seems like a
good idea to me you're just you're
tracking it to its conclusion though and
seeing holes in that you know in the in
that equation yeah so i think
and plow it i'm very favored of it as
long as it's like the first step
so
you know maybe you get someone to like
go skydiving for charity and
uh it's on balance not doing that much
good uh
and they feel like they did their
charitable act for the year yeah so
that's the bad outcome because if
there's no follow-up at all but if
however they say oh wow that was
terrific i had like loads of fun and
then say okay well how about you do this
additional thing maybe something more
again and then it actually starts to
feel like oh yeah this was like the
first step that i was taking
and in the case of the ice bucket
challenge there wasn't that and again
that's no one's fault it's because it's
just this viral phenomenon you know
people pour water in their heads and
then they go back to
their day-to-day lives i'd be pretty
surprised if actually people like many
people were
then you know significantly changing
their life as a result of um
as a result of that all right so a
couple other controversial ideas that
you have one of them is around fair
trade yeah
uh yeah so
the general idea of ethical consumption
um in favor of you know
could work in theory uh but then fair
trade in particular i think is a very
bad implementation
of that idea and that's for a few
reasons
the first is just that the additional
money you spend on fair trade goods
relative to non-fair trade goods of that
a very small percentage actually ends up
in the hands of producers
and possibly
none of it ends up tickling down to the
wages of the poorest people who are the
farmers working in say coffee right so
it's not it's not a conceptual uh
disagreement it's an implementation it's
an implementation thing yeah um
uh so yeah because and that's just a few
just ways in which i think it's badly
implemented so that's one um although
that's going to be very hard to get
around because supermarkets are going to
use this as a way to
do what's called price discrimination
yeah which is that uh you're willing to
pay more for an ethical product
i'm gonna just charge as much as i can
even and i can say oh and this is an
ethical product even if a very small
percentage that's actually going to
benefit yeah i mean that's what's
happening right now with organic
labeling uh it's become commodified yeah
right so it becomes a premium brand to
have that certification and that label
on a food product
and you know food producers know this
supermarkets know this and the governing
organizat the usda knows this so then
what happens is lobbying efforts are
applied that uh begin to um
devalue the the organic certification it
gets watered down yeah right so it
doesn't quite mean what it used to mean
and you know organizations are charged a
lot to get the certification
and they're able to now produce foods
that aren't quite as organic as they
were maybe five years ago still meet the
standard they can charge more and it
just becomes a business so the under the
underlying idea behind it is quite good
it's just not quite what people think it
is and i feel like it's similar with
fair trade yeah although
yeah no i think that's right although i
think there are
even additional problems with fair trade
so one is
because i mean that's an example of
you know for profits co-opting it right
and like i guess the kind of additional
price being charged for fair trade um
well sorry starbucks can charge more
yeah if they tell you this is fair trade
yeah and we don't really spend any time
really analyzing what's actually going
on yeah yeah that's and i don't know
what what is so i'm not like pointing
fingers again yeah but i think there's
even additional problems beyond that so
one is the fact that with fair trade
production
uh it's hard to get a certification um
in effect it kind of costs these horses
and so
most fertility coffee production doesn't
come from the poorest countries like
ethiopia and kenya comes from places
like
uh mexico colombia or costa rica uh
where again you know they're not rich
countries but they're 10 times richer
than ethiopia kenya and so the
additional earnings just aren't doing as
much good
and then the final thing is just
the way the fair trade model works is by
giving two dollars
or it gives a price premium a certain
amount of money
in addition to the market price for the
goods bought
and that's great for the fair trade
producers it means they can sell their
goods at higher price
but
um through the laws of supply and demand
it means that fair trade coffee is going
to be oversupplied uh it means that
non-fair trade farmers are going to be
made worse off
and that's why i'm like most deeply
ambivalent about fair traders but isn't
that a market force that would compel
other suppliers to become fair trade
uh there's only a
i mean if you could have everyone
that was
fair trade
then
you wouldn't i guess you wouldn't have
people being um made worse off but you
still would have coffee over supply so
you'd have a lot of coffee going to
waste which would seem
uh inefficient
um
but at the moment uh you know the vast
majority of coffee production is still
not fair trade and so if you do have
some people
uh some producers
uh kind of supplying more than the
market wants that is just gonna make
fair trade workers
uh worse off as a result because they
won't be able to sell goods i mean i
feel like the biggest thing is just the
trickle down of actually getting it to
the farmers yeah because i think that's
what the consumer is operating under
when they're making that choice they
want to know that it was fairly produced
which implicitly means that you know
you're taking care of the actual
not the boss of the you know like the
actual farmers yeah i mean in particular
compared to just firstly buying just the
cheapest car the coffee that's just
produced in the cheapest countries
sorry in the poorest countries where um
the money is going to go furthest and
then secondly donating the difference so
cutting out the middlemen cutting out
starbucks and all the retailers that are
taking a cut each time yeah and just
giving tim yes
well i mean it's the same who's going to
do that simple just buy the cheapest
goods that's easy set of a direct debit
to give directly um
which just transfers cash to the poorest
people in
kenya tanzania
um what could be simpler how do you set
up that direct do you do it can you do
that through through your organization
uh yeah i mean if you want you can give
to
so given what we can as a trust um and
if you're giving what we can member you
can donate through the trust if not you
can set up a direct debit if you give
well and they'll distribute it to their
top organizations or in this case of
give directly you could just go straight
onto the give directly website right all
right
all right final controversial subject
sweatshops
what is going on here yeah so again i
think this is a case of kind of good
intentions gone wrong with respect to
uh
the attempt to boycott sweatshop
produced goods
and yeah so you had lion holiday on the
show recently he was the chief marketing
officer for american apparel which you
know as a marketing campaign
uh claims okay we are sweatshop for you
we do not use sweatshops use goods
um we do not use sweatshops we just
only employ people in america um or
other kind of well like much literature
countries
uh and so people think okay i shouldn't
buy goods produced in sweatshops i
should buy from american apparel i think
that's a very bad outcome for the poor
uh and because they're not they're
they're otherwise unemployed you're
saying it's either either there's either
no employment or there's poor condition
employment that's right all than worse
jobs prostitution um sleep hustling uh
scavenging from dumps so sweatshops are
pretty herbific places you know
no one's disputing that at all they're
not nice places to work
but
extreme poverty is just very extreme
indeed and they're actually the best
jobs going around they actually are the
job they are typically paying much more
than
um
other jobs available in the area and
you know the people working there
choosing to work there
in fact often
emigrating across borders risking
deportation so that they can work these
sweatshop jobs and so if you're taking
away those sweatshops then
uh
um then you're taking away the best
working opportunities that people in the
poorest countries have but isn't i mean
do you extrapolate on that argument i
mean couldn't that be
you know it almost sounds like an
argument a slave owner would make you
know it's like well i can either you
know have this guy as my slave or he'll
just be wandering you know unemployable
and will perish you know in the
wilderness so i'm actually doing him a
favor by providing him an option and
putting up putting a roof over his head
yeah so to to give the most extreme
right
so i think the cases are quite different
because um the people who work in
sweatshops you know it's their voluntary
choice to go and work there and in fact
it's you know they're enthusiastic about
working there relative to those options
and i agree we want to un like we want
to end the underlying poverty that makes
sweatshops desirable place to work
um and that's why you know campaign for
people to donate like far more or to you
know try and make systemic change
uh so that we evaluate sweatshops by
actually just eradicating poverty um
but yeah it's a voluntary choice that
people make to work there and it's so
banning it is just like taking away um
uh
yeah banning it is taking away the best
option that they have
whereas in you know
the slavery case um
it's well firstly the person would have
many options to
benefit the slave in
many other ways and secondly um
if it's an option if they're like well
you can do as you do as you wish if you
want to keep yeah you can be my slave as
long as you want to and if you want to
leave you can leave and not be my slave
i mean then that's no longer slavery but
right right right all right so by by
virtue of your
your logic like i should feel
less guilty about the iphone in my
pocket oh yeah because there's there's
this weird dissonance like okay i'm
trying to align my actions with my
values but you know i'll still i still
have an iphone you know and i know
intellectually that this was produced
uh under circumstances that are less
than ideal
um
that i'm disconnected with from you know
like i don't i don't really know what
goes on in that factory in china where
my
i hear rumors you know
and it's the same it's the same
dissonance that occurs with somebody who
doesn't like the idea of killing animals
but will buy ground ground beef at the
supermarket it really is no different
you know what i mean
but by your argument like
i should say
it's okay that i have my iphone because
these people are employed well i think
you should go the other way actually so
i think you should think
take that feeling of kind of model and
comfort that you have when buying an
iphone and thinking of those horrific um
conditions
and then channel that to try and end the
underlying poverty so you wouldn't have
had that um
you wouldn't have had that discomfort if
you hadn't been doing anything but now
you feel somewhat involved
it can't be morally but you've benefited
people um in the course of doing that
just a little bit by um providing better
job opportunities
but that act has made salient actually
how bad the lives of some people in the
um
on the other side of the world are and
so i think that's like good that we have
that moral discomfort but reacting to it
by not um by just saying okay i'm going
to keep my hands clean and just you know
then i don't have to think about this at
all right
doing nothing is is the worst option
yeah and then it's a distinction between
um
a symptomatic or an underlying causal
approach right like by not buying the
iphone you're kind of dealing with the
symptom
buying it or not buying it like you're
in this the the factory and the people
that are employed there is symptomatic
of an underlying cause which is poverty
right so so actually channeling your
resources and your energy towards
addressing the underlying poverty
would be a better option in the same way
that you would treat a disease by
getting at the underlying cause as
opposed to the pharmaceutical that masks
whatever symptom
is a result of that
yeah i think that's exactly like that
condition right yeah
i like that oh good
maybe maybe i've got a convert all right
cool so we got a let's see oh we've been
gone an hour and a half we'll wrap it up
here soon so
one of the things that's in your in your
book doing good better is you kind of
have these five questions uh
that are basically like the decision
tree to entertain when you're looking at
you know how to allocate your resources
so why don't we just run through those
really quickly so that okay it's a good
way to kind of like cap it off yeah so
the first question
um which we talked about earlier is
uh how many people benefit and by how
much
um so that's the key is just thinking
about your impact in terms of
improvements to people's lives more
people you can benefit by greater the
amount the better
the second question is is this the most
effective thing i can do
and that's the idea of making the most
difference not just making a difference
because even among very good ways of
doing good the best are hundreds of
times better than
um
just merely good
um sorts of activities
uh so you need to always think not just
is this making some impact business
making the most impact i can
third question is is this area neglected
so
because things in general have
diminishing returns
uh it's vital to focus on you know the
poorest people in the world or those
cause areas that don't get as much
attention us education's you know
important cause but so much
philanthropic funding already going to
it it's hard to make a big difference
fourth question is what would have
happened otherwise
uh and that
question says the difference you make is
the difference between how much could
you do and how much good it would have
been done even if you hadn't acted
um i talk about the impact a doctor has
where
you know as a doctor you're saving lives
every single day but for most of those
lives they would have been saved anyway
even if you hadn't taken that job and so
the actual impact you have the
difference you've made to the world i
think is much less than you might
intuitively think by becoming a doctor
and then the final question is
uh
what are the chances of success and how
good would success be
and that's a crucial question when
you're thinking about
uh
uncertain ways of doing good you know
things that maybe won't pay off but
might have a really big impact like
systemic change or
something other than these concrete
measurable ways of doing good
uh and that's this concept called
expected value
multiplying the chance of success
by the value of the success if you do it
and that provides this way of thinking
about systemic change
and then
those are the kind of five underlying
questions if you're thinking like that
you're thinking like an effective art
twist it's the kind of power tools for
doing good
um and then the second half of the book
applies that to doing good for charity
doing good through career doing through
good through your consumption and
thinking about what are the most
important causes what are the biggest
problems in the world the ones we should
be really trying to tackle
yeah i love it i mean the book is really
great it definitely uh changed
the way that i think about all of this
um
certainly changes how i perceive you
know the world of charitable giving and
i would recommend everybody check it out
it's very cool man it's uh you've done a
great service by putting this out there
cool thank you yeah it's cool and if if
you're inspired
um by professor mccaskill
uh and interested in learning more about
uh about giving i mean you can go to
giving what we can and learn more um
about what that organization does and if
you're interested in trying to figure
out
how to allocate your next gift
givewell.org that's a good place to go
too right yeah that's great and if you
want to do good for your career then 80
thousand hours.org is right is the place
so i took the test
i did it said i should be a politician
or a startup entrepreneur i think both
of those things are pretty good for you
yes i don't know
i need the big idea for the startup
entrepreneur though so i can come back
and do what you're doing which is
participating in y a combinator so why
don't we cap it off with with that so
you're here we're in mountain view right
now just down the street from stanford
and you're participating in a very
prestigious sort of venture capital uh
how would you describe it compendium con
it's not a conference but it's sort of
like all these startups you've been
invited it's like an accelerator for new
startups or an incubator yeah
so it's a way of taking early safe
startups and really getting them off the
ground and it's produced to companies
like blockbox leddit airbnb
uh and so it's the kind of premiere of
accelerator in the world and recently
they started taking non-profits and
we're one of them so yeah how many i
mean how many non-profits have gone
through there how many yeah less than 10
i think um i think out of 130 companies
in this batch for non-profits right
and so you know i think y combinator
definitely still kind of figured out
exactly
i mean you're still finding their feet
with non-profits
because obviously it's you know very
different set of standards than the for
profits
but there's similar things that apply to
both and this has been one of the most
valuable learning experiences of my life
i think it's pretty cool so they kind of
they mentor you but there's also a
little bit of a competitive dog and pony
show right where you have to get up
there and you got to pitch yeah
you know pretty intimidating audience of
potential investors etc yeah so it all
culminates in demo day where
all the companies stand up they pitch
for two and a half minutes to 450
investors
um and then afterwards there's this
crazy meat market where everyone tries
to meet everyone else and
uh the startups are looking for
investment we're looking for donations
um
and
there's a little app so that investors
can like different companies and then
they you'll get an email sent and you
can be in touch afterwards sahara girl
um you already did that part yeah we've
done that part went really well
so it was ben todd the ceo of 80 000
hours that was presenting and i thought
he nailed it which
i was happy with and then yeah i had a
bunch of people really interested in
what we were doing
in particularly as a donation
opportunity you know we did set up 80
000 hours with the
intention of being the most cost
effective charity in the world because
you know where encouraging people to
work and the most important causes or
donate to the most cost effective
charities yeah you better better walk
that walk right if you're saying like
you know make sure you understand where
your money's going and that it's
actually having an impact and then
you're saying please donate to us oh
yeah so we're better yeah we're very
aware of that especially given you know
they could be donating to these amazing
first order charities but we're like a
meta charity where like right kind of
like we're raising resources for the
most
um effective causes and most um
effective generations
uh effective altruists yeah yeah that's
partly what we're doing um and you know
making the people who are already trying
to do good more effective because
they're having
better knowledge about what to do with
her life and so
uh yeah we think that
um
you know money coming in through us is
like a tenfold or maybe a hundredfold
multiplier or something so uh it's like
an investment it's like a way of getting
leverage in your donation right and from
here you're almost done here and then
you're heading off to oxford so yeah
i'll very shortly be going back to
oxford where i'm starting um an
associate professorship uh so what are
you going to teach so in teaching ethics
political philosophy as you'd expect
yeah yeah um i'll be i won't don't
merely push effective altitudes and
it'll be much more impartial than that
um but yeah i'm very lucky to be
starting at lincoln college oxford
university so undergraduate yeah
undergraduate and graduates yeah and the
arts systems you're going to be teaching
people that are
might be older than you yeah that's
probably true
um
uh
yeah which
i mean even with the undergraduates i
don't feel so different than when i
walked into came the jj into 18 so uh
i'll need to be yeah well i don't either
but you know that's how it goes well
that's an interesting dynamic though to
be to be i mean you're essentially a
peer
right yeah i mean obviously i'm gonna
have to try and create this uh
create a dynamic where you know i am the
tutor and costuming
yeah a little bit right so i won't be
wearing this t-shirt you know wearing a
nice shirt and so on no no chuck
taylor's
um
uh but i think you know i think there's
also advanced real advantages there like
i actually know like really remember
it's very salient what it's like being
you know turning up a cambridge so
scared um
suddenly surrounded by all these people
are so high performing and you know it's
very easy to beat yourself up very easy
to feel like an imposter
and so i think that
the kind of empathy still being quite
young will give me it's going to be an
asset in terms of teaching well good
luck man yeah thanks uh your work is
inspiring i can't wait to see you know
where this all leads for you and uh i
appreciate your time man yeah thank you
so much for having me yeah it's cool so
all right if you're digging on uh on
professor mccaskill i'm going to create
a little formality here
you can go to his website
williammccaskill.com or you can go to
8000hz.com
you can go to
givingwhatwecan.org
and also maybe most importantly
effectivealtruism.com if you want to get
involved and figure out uh how to create
community around these ideas where you
live is that fair to say yeah that's
right cool is there anything else you're
at will mccaskill on twitter will
mccaskill on twitter and the book uh
doing good better doing it better of
course guide to effective autism it's
out now yeah definitely pick it up where
all books are sold all right cool man
thanks thank you peace
[Music]
you